AMY KRISHNAMOHAN:
Thanks, everyone.
My name is Amy Krishnamohan.
I do product marketing
at Google Cloud.
I'm here with really exciting
guest speakers today,
Joe and Seph from Kolide
and the 6 River Systems.
Today we're going to
talk a little bit more
about how you can build
a SaaS application
in the cloud-based
infrastructure.
So SaaS has changed
a lot, right?
When you had more on-prem,
hardware-based environment,
having a single tenancy was
actually really expensive
but is very secure.
But cloud
infrastructure actually
made a really drastic
change in terms
of making these
instances available
very easily at your hand.
So SaaS is obviously making
leading changes in that area.
So here I'll
introduce our guest.
Joe, would you like
to take it from here?
JOE HUGHES: Hey, I'm Joe Hughes.
I'm director of devops
at 6 River Systems.
Six River Systems is
a robotic company.
When you get things shipped
to you from the internet,
we have a big hand
in making sure
that those things can get to
you in two days or faster.
And I was previously
at a company called
Amazon Robotics in that
space, and you probably
know them as Kiva.
They solve the same problem.
So that's our robot.
His name is Chuck.
And essentially
Chuck leads a worker
around a warehouse using kind
of self-driving technology,
identifying objects
in the way and taking
that person to fulfill
your order of toothbrushes
or whatever you happened
to order off the internet.
This is what those
warehouses look like.
So this isn't your Home
Depot or your Target store.
This is thousands and
thousands of products,
million-square-foot warehouses.
And so we have algorithms
in the cloud that
helps us batch these
orders and get efficiencies
for our customers and
make sure that Chuck
or the mini Chucks that
are in these warehouses
coordinate together and make
life better for our customers.
So if you're not familiar
with warehouse robotics,
traditionally what
you would be doing
is carrying around
a big cart weighing
upwards of 50 to 100 pounds.
Now you can follow
Chuck around and have
a more enjoyable workday.
Basically, this is
just a quick look
at our high-level architecture.
And this is kind of what Amy was
alluding to is we have a Google
Kubernetes Engine cluster--
Kubernetes is a
container scheduler--
where we create what
are called namespaces,
which basically isolate
customers from one another.
We actually run these namespaces
on dedicated nodes, which
is like dedicated
compute, and we actually
have a dedicated SQL
primary and a read replica
for every single customer.
So that means that
data from one warehouse
never gets mixed with another.
So that's a little
bit about what I do
and what my company does.
I'm going to hand
it over to Seph
to kind of fill you in
on what Kolide does.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
Hi, everyone.
I'm Seph.
I'm an SRE at Kolide,
which does sort
of infrastructure analytics
and security analytics.
Previously I've been at
Fastly, Twitter, ActBlue.
I like infrastructure as
code, data simplification,
stuff like that.
Kolide builds an endpoint that
hangs out on devices, primarily
laptops, and collects
analytics about that
and sends it into
our cloud where
we do some analysis on it.
We launched Cloud, which is
our SaaS offering, about a year
ago now.
And in that, each customer has
an isolated namespace, very
similar to what Joe is doing.
And each namespace has its own
little stack of application,
server, and
data-processing elements,
and those back call to
dedicated Cloud SQL instances.
So kind of did that
because it reduces
the noisy-neighbor problems.
It also shifts the
burden of data isolation
from application developers
to infrastructure.
We dedicate
infrastructure resources
to ensure data segregation,
and then we can take it out
of the application.
We do share our edge ingress.
So edge is shared, and
it then comes in and gets
sort of pushed into the back.
We use Kubernetes
quite extensively.
We follow the operator pattern.
So each customer has a
custom resource definition,
and then an operator
goes and reads the CRD,
spawns the namespace,
creates many deployments.
Each one brings up things,
brings up Cloud SQL.
We started running into issues
around the number of namespaces
and things that can be in a
single Kubernetes cluster,
so we have multiple
Kubernetes clusters now.
We found that some
of the spin-up times
were a little
slow, so we started
precreating unallocated
customers and then, on sign up,
would allocate them.
We are very soon launching
a new product next week
which moves away from the
single-tenant architecture
and starts revisiting
multitenant designs.
So that uses foreign keys
for customer data isolation,
and this is enforced
at a data layer
by making sure there are
effectively SQL WHERE
clauses all over.
So it's basically
our data library,
and we could shard that by
customer to separate back ends.
So I think that's all
I've got prepared.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Great.
Thanks.
So before we get
started, there is
a Dory open in your mobile app.
So if you have any questions,
feel free to submit a question.
We'll take the
questions at the end.
And so there are
many ways that we
can define the multitenant
environment, right?
Everybody defines it
in very different way.
So how would you
define multitenant
in the cloud environment?
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS: I guess
I have the mic, so I'll start.
I think there is a whole lot
of ways to think about that.
We run in Google's cloud,
so inherently Google's cloud
is multitenant.
Probably almost everyone in
this room is in Google's cloud.
But we run on our own
Kubernetes cluster,
but our Kubernetes cluster
is also multitenant
because many of our customers
are in the same Kubernetes
cluster, so our Kubernetes
cluster is single tenant.
But each daemon or pod inside--
and Kubernetes workloads
are grouped by pod.
So a pod is like a set
of linked containers.
And each pod is single tenant.
So only one customer
is in a pod.
And our underlying database
is we use Cloud SQL.
We have one Cloud SQL
instance per customer.
So that's also a very
clear single tenant.
So it kind of depends
on where you look at it.
I would generally
describe our cloud product
as being single tenant since
Google Cloud being multitenant
isn't really very interesting,
but our application servers
and our database servers are.
JOE HUGHES: Yeah, I don't
really have much to add to that.
I would say that a lot
of it also comes down
to your business problem.
And for us, when
we considered what
we should build we
were like, well,
we have long lead times
with our customers,
and they may or may not
want us to upgrade them.
And so what is this
architecture called?
And it's called single
tenant because we
have really tight control over
how our customer environment is
managed.
That works well
for us, but if you
were a building a
social-media platform
or something like
that, it's probably
not the right
architecture for you.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: So you're
defining single tenant
is having a customer
per pod, and then also
each single customer would have
a dedicated database instance.
JOE HUGHES: Yeah.
And we go a step
further than Seph
where we actually have dedicated
Google Cloud Platform nodes
that Kubernetes will only
schedule customer pods
and customer workloads
onto those dedicated nodes.
Where I know Seph,
as he spoke about,
his is more multitenant where
a customer's pod can end up
on any node, and
they may move around.
Whereas ours, we try to
protect our customers
by having dedicated compute.
Kubernetes is so flexible
that it makes it easy for Seph
to do his thing and for me to
do it a little bit different.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: So when you
designed your architecture,
what was your biggest
consideration?
JOE HUGHES: For us, it's really
about customer stability.
I think everyone here
would be really angry
if the socks that
were guaranteed
to come to you in two days
were there two weeks later.
And if we caused that
because our system was
down for some reason
for some amount time,
then our customers
aren't going to trust us.
So we have to really
guarantee that customer A--
you know, the
noisy-neighbor problem,
we can't even let it enter
the equation for our system.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
We had two major drivers
for going single tenant
for our last product.
One of them was to reduce
noisy neighbor a lot.
So again, one customer
does a lot of stuff,
basically starves the
resources of other people,
so we started
splitting up resources.
The other reason is just
around data isolation.
Again, it makes it very easy
for an application developer
just not even think about it.
You can be like, oh,
there's no way I can select
data for the wrong customer.
It's just that app server
doesn't have access to that.
So that was a big driver for us.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: I see.
So going back more
on the database side,
have you guys ever tried
putting a multitenant
in a single database, like
maybe separating them by the key
or by table, things like that?
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
So we do actually.
So I mentioned we're
launching a new product.
Our new product has
a shared database.
So each customer has their
foreign-key constraints.
Every piece of data is
linked to a customer ID,
and there are WHERE
classes all over.
But again, it's just
this tradeoff of,
are you doing the
data isolation work
in your application
at the SQL level
or at an infrastructure level?
So you can go both ways.
JOE HUGHES: So our
company, another factor
of why we haven't looked into
that situation was just time.
We knew that there
would be tradeoffs,
and that it's more
developer time
to do those sort of things.
And so where we can
shift complexity away
from our developers and
shift it onto Google, which
is what we were
really doing, that
made it an easy call for us to
just continue with that model.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
Actually, as I think about this,
one of the ongoing tradeoffs for
us around number of instances
is just straight up
number of instances.
When we had 10
instances, it was easy.
But as the number of tenants we
have increases and increases,
we're suddenly now managing--
or Google is managing many,
many, many Cloud SQL instances.
And it mostly works great,
but as a single person
managing them, it
gets much harder
for me to track down problems.
So the number of things
to pay attention to--
I don't know.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN:
That's interesting.
So now that we
talk about instance
so I'm sure when
your customers create
their account in
the application,
I'm sure they want kind of
instant creation, right?
But creating the database
instance or node or the pod,
it takes time.
So how do you manage
that latency issue?
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
I'll start.
So we have-- sign up
is available online.
So people can just kind of
go, hey, I want to sign up.
And we used to have a slightly
asynchronous sign-up flow.
People would click Sign Up.
We'd send them an email, and
then they'd click their email.
And behind the scenes while
that email was being delivered,
we would spin up a database.
We'd spin up a tenant.
And we had a couple
of issues with that.
One of them is that we wanted
to close that loop even tighter.
We didn't want people to
have to wait for their email.
And the other one
is occasionally
instance creation would
fail, and we never
really built failure handling.
So we solved that by
preallocating things.
So we had a little daemon that
runs in the background that
says make sure there are roughly
30 free tenants at any given
time.
So we just sort
of have headroom.
And then when someone
signs up it says,
hey, give me the next
free one, gets a free.
Then it basically says, this
now belongs to this company,
and then it's used.
And then a little while later
the daemon goes, oh hey, look,
I need to create a new free one.
So we've sort of
tackled that loop
by having a precreated model.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: How do
you come up with that 30
unallocated instances?
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
Just kind of made it up.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN:
It's a random number.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
I looked at what do we
get from a day of sign ups?
What's our peak?
How much headroom do we
want to have lying around?
I picked a number.
We used to adjust it more
often, but now it's just--
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: No AI and
machine learning predicted?
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
No, not on that one.
JOE HUGHES: For us,
it's a little bit easier
because you can't just go
online and sign up for Chuck.
You have to engage
with our team,
and there's a long
integration period
where you have to integrate
with customers' systems.
So a 10-minute creation
time is lightning fast
for our industry, and we're
really happy with that.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN:
So it seems like you
both guys are using the
Kubernetes right now.
So how do use Kubernetes
in your SaaS application?
JOE HUGHES: You saw a little
bit of that in my slide.
I think Kubernetes is
really great because
of its flexibility where
you can isolate things
by namespace, Istio.
We have a lot of customers
that are very concerned
about security.
There's potentially
personal information
in some of the things
that we handle.
And so that isolation with
namespaces and encryption
by default, which the Istio
service mesh kind of gives you,
are all really
powerful tools for us
that we just get by
using the platform.
So we really reach for
all of those things
to make it easier to manage.
As Seph kind of
alluded to, we've
grown our customer
base quite a bit,
and so there's a nontrivial
amount of SQL instances
to manage, and there's
a nontrivial amount
of namespaces and pods.
But that's where Stackdriver
and a lot of the other products
that Google offers really
come in to help you.
But yeah, I would say that
the continuous release
of new features in
Kubernetes has made
it a really great thing for us.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
Yeah, we love Kubernetes.
It's great.
I sort of think of it as it's
a nice abstraction for defining
workloads.
So we define workloads, and
then Kubernetes just kind of
makes them happen.
And we heavily use namespaces
as our isolation model.
We also have really done a
lot in the Kubernetes operator
model, which has a thing,
CoreOS, declared a while ago.
And that means we
create custom resources.
Resources are like an internal
Kubernetes thing, pile of YAML.
And the resource basically
says this is a customer.
They should get
this many resources.
They're big, medium,
small, and make them go.
And then we have
an operator that
comes along, reads
all the resources,
and creates the namespace,
creates all the pods,
creates the Cloud SQL instance.
And so yeah,
Kubernetes is great,
and I really like
the operator pattern.
It lets me take my knowledge
of how to create and manage
these things and
translate it into code
that just runs and synchronizes
itself and kind of just
goes in the background and
fixes, fixes, fixes, fixes.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: And
the other tools you're
using together with
Kubernetes, Terraform?
JOE HUGHES: Yeah, so as you
might have guessed from Amy,
we use Terraform.
We're actually on the
journey to where Seph already
is where the operator pattern,
we've watched it closely
and kind of seen people
apply it successfully.
Again, we're in
an industry where
we have to be a little
bit more cautious.
So we have to kind of
watch things and make sure
that they mature in the way
that we really think that we can
make a long-term bet on them.
Kubernetes is a no-brainer.
The operating pattern, it
is a pattern, and so for us
we had to see people
successfully apply it.
And there's a lot of great
examples out there now
and a lot of great stories
from people like Seph
who have applied
it, so that's where
we're going to be going next.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: So Joe, you
touched about the securities.
In the multitenant environment,
how do you isolate tenant
to avoid any security concern?
Is there any specific
thing that you can share?
JOE HUGHES: Yeah, I
think just by the nature
of having the single tenancy
you alleviate almost all
of that concern.
There are certain
customers where
they want that
data to be on-prem,
and that's a whole another
thing that you have to address.
But in a multitenant
application,
again, I think you really have
to look at your business case.
I've worked for companies that
were under HIPAA compliance.
And so in a
multitenant application
that has to have
HIPAA compliance,
you have to have
row-level encryption.
And then you have to
reach for some tools
like Vault, which is a
HashiCorp product that
allows you to have encryption
as a service or other things
like that.
Because it's not just
enough that you can--
if someone was to access
it, they can't even
be able to decrypt it.
And so business case
is what you really
need to think about in a
lot of these situations.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
Yeah, I'm not
sure I have much to add
on the single-tenant side.
It is a great answer for
very strong data isolation.
That said, if you
go multitenant,
you're basically
pushing that burden
to the application layer.
In our multitenant world, we
do it via the database adaptor
just enforces that, oh,
this is a call for data?
It had better have
an appropriate WHERE
tenet equals x clause on it.
And frequently to
handle the needs
of really sensitive
customers, you
end up sharding by customer.
So you end up in a
bit of a hybrid where
most things are multitenant,
but this one is special.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: How about
the noisy-neighbor problem?
How do you do the--
perform the isolation?
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
Well, single tenant
makes that pretty easy.
In Kubernetes, you still have
to think about it a little bit.
So our pods are scheduled
onto the same nodes.
So we have to make sure
that our pod resource
allocations are correct.
So each of our pods is allocated
so much CPU and so much RAM,
and then Kubernetes
will just enforce that.
And that's how we approach
the noisy-neighbor problem.
JOE HUGHES: Yeah, I kind
of gave it away earlier,
but we actually had a--
we were doing what Seph
did, and a bug in our code
essentially was causing
cascading failures where
we were bringing
down an entire node,
and there was multiple
customers on that node.
And so our tech-support team
had a lot of angry phone
calls all at the same time.
So I ended up pulling over
to the side of the road
and doing a lot of
work on my laptop
on the side of the highway.
So after that we were
like, OK, in the future
when we have more resources
and our company is more mature
and we can really get a lot
of great people like Seph
and other people like
that, we can attack this.
But for now it's easier,
again, to push that complexity
to Google, say
we're going to have
node pools for every
single customer,
and we're going to set up the
Kubernetes rules to make sure
that no two customers can
end up on the same node
so if something does happen
and we roll out a bug like that
again, it's going to
be completely isolated.
That is not a long-term
solution, probably,
but for now it's something
that we can live with,
and it's helped us continue
to build our business.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS: I've
actually sort of got a--
we run into a certain
problem around this
which maybe is funny if people
want to hear about Kubernetes
problems.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: No.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
No, it's great.
What we've seen is Kubernetes
itself can be a little weird.
It's not quite a noisy neighbor,
but it's almost similar.
The underlying Kubernetes
resource requirements per node
are not small.
So they're actually substantial.
Each node has a
given load, so you
have to be cognizant of that.
And the other thing we've run
into-- which, I don't know,
I giggle about it, but it's
been a bit of a pain point--
is some operations we do, if
we go to like upgrade every one
right, we're basically
running a redeploy
on every one of our tenants.
And what we found is that
the Kubernetes master
can get overwhelmed with
that very easily, and then
everything breaks.
So it's very bad when your
Kubernetes master breaks.
So to sort of approach
that scaling and kind
of noisy neighbor, we basically
just rate limit what we do.
So we found that we have to
be very deliberate in how
we roll out upgrades because
otherwise the Kubernetes
master just tries to
do everything at once,
and then it melts.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: So how many
pods do you put per node?
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS: This is
another problem we've run into.
Running in Google,
Kubernetes has
a limit of 110 pods per
node, which most people are
OK with because you
normally run about 30,
and this is kind
of a pod resource
to node capacity question.
A lot of our services
are very small,
and we have a large number of
tenants, so we pack them a bit.
But what I've found is
when we exceed about 50,
things start going wonky.
It's just there's a lot of
auto scaling in the Kubernetes
system, and a lot of the scaling
around Kubernetes metrics
collection and logs collection
is based on the idea
that you will only have
about 30 pods per node.
So as you start pushing
that higher and higher,
you run into these points
where things you didn't expect
could break would break.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: I see.
So you recommend about 30?
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS: Yes.
I would recommend not exceeding
30 to 50 pods per node.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: So do you
have any scaling experience?
Like maybe in Black Friday, I'm
sure you guys are very busy.
JOE HUGHES: Yeah, so as all of
you would probably recognize,
our customers can have
something like a 20x peak
where everyone wants to order
something on Black Friday,
and they want it the next day.
And so for us, that's
where Kubernetes really
shines for us also is,
OK, we all of a sudden got
20 times the orders
that our system normally
needs to ingest.
And so being able to both scale
vertically and horizontally
inside Kubernetes gives us
the flexibility to kind of not
have to worry
about that as much.
We obviously take a
lot of precautions
and we try to be ready for
that, but as a technology,
it's really enabled us to,
again, do more with less.
And that's really what I
think a startup is all about
is you need to keep your
most talented people focused
on the product and not focused
on, oh no, we need more nodes.
Click the button more.
And that's where
Kubernetes comes in.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
Maybe sort
of thinking a bit about
that-- though this
might be a future question.
I don't know.
Sorry, Amy.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: It's OK.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
One of the things
that helps us a lot
in handling sort
of momentary bursts in traffic
is we have a predominantly
asynchronous pipeline.
We're trying to reason
about things on a minute
to couple-of-minute timeline.
So if a big burst
comes in, it's kind
of just going to hang out in a
queue until we can process it.
So as long as our
queues have capacity,
it's OK if our processing
is a little bit lagging.
And I can't speak for Joe, but
I bet there's something similar.
JOE HUGHES: We're getting there.
You think about logistics
and these companies,
they're often very old.
And so we're integrating
with systems that expect
transactions, for example.
So we don't care that we gave
you 2 million things to do.
We're just going to sit here
and wait for you to tell us
if you did 2 million things.
So a lot of our
infrastructure needs to just
really be able to absorb that.
We do some batching
and everything else,
but it's a problem that
is difficult to solve.
And the infrastructure can't
always solve that problem,
but good design where you build
queues and everything else
can help.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Now let's
move on to more customizability.
So you guys have a
single-tenant environment,
so how similar to each
tenant the characteristic,
and if the one tenant needs a
very different characteristic,
how do you customize
those things?
JOE HUGHES: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
For us, it's kind of around
the size of our system.
So customer A has 8 Chucks
and customer B has 50.
We put those numbers in,
and out the other side pops,
oh, well they should get
this size of database,
or they should get
this size of node pool
or this amount of resources
because we exactly how
a Chuck's going to behave.
It's a little bit
more difficult if you
have users or other things
that you can't really predict.
But luckily, we kind of control
both sides of the equation
there.
So it can be really
prescriptive for us.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
We probably
have about maybe five
variables per customer.
I don't remember offhand,
but it's about five.
And we implement that by
environmental variables.
So our application
says, hey, what's
the value of this
environmental variable,
and it behaves a
little differently.
And then we just control those
in our Kubernetes operator
pattern.
Our custom resource
definition has some settings.
The operator pushes those
in as deployment variables,
and then it all just kind
of follows from there.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: That's great.
So now let's move on to
cross-tenant environment.
So when you need
to do analytics in
the cross-tenant environment,
how do you do that?
Are you using any data
warehousing environment?
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
We don't have that need,
so we haven't done it.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: None.
JOE HUGHES: We do,
as you would imagine,
really want to know about
all of our customers,
and so it is an
interesting problem for us.
And we rely on BigQuery a lot.
And so all of our robots
are sending information
through Cloud IoT.
That gets pumped into BigQuery.
And then we also have
some data pipelines
that go and go to all of our
SQL instances and scrape data,
shove it into BigQuery.
So we have one place where
we can look at all of that.
And we're lucky enough to be
involved with kind of an alpha
where Cloud SQL is able to be
queried by BigQuery directly.
And so we'll be happy
to kind of get rid
of that scraping situation.
But it's really important.
That is something
that is a good thing
to reason about is if you're
going to have that need.
Seph doesn't, but
we definitely do
because we need to
find efficiencies
across all of our
tenants, and so that's
really important for us.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: I see.
And how do you forecast your
demand, like capacity planning?
I know you talked
about the 30 instances,
that you keep it in
your back pocket.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS: I
mean, our capacity planning
is relatively simple.
We sort of look at what
our marketing is like
and are we going to a
conference, do we expect
sign ups, that kind of thing.
And then we just kind of say,
eh, about this, and we do it.
And overestimate
it a little bit.
Don't think too hard.
We're still a very
small company.
We don't have this.
I guess the other sort of
implicit piece of that is
we don't have to buy hardware.
We're just saying, hey, Google,
instead of 30, give me 32.
It's no different to me.
It's a minute either way.
JOE HUGHES: Yeah,
I think we also
have a pretty nice luxury
where we kind of know.
Our customers even
tell us how many orders
they expect on
their Black Friday.
And so we prepare for that by
doing a lot of load testing,
and that really
helps us understand,
uh oh, this needs to
auto scale this way,
or we need to prepare
our environment this way.
So a little easier
for us because we're
dealing with large
enterprise businesses.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: Do you
guys do any stress testing
in your environment?
JOE HUGHES: Yeah, actually
one of the cool things that we
do in Kubernetes-- as
you probably can imagine,
if we need to test
a hundred robots,
we can't really just go with a
hundred robots to a warehouse
and deploy them.
That's kind of a lot of money.
So we actually
run our simulator.
So we run the same
code that runs
in the robots in Kubernetes.
We scale it up to
silly things that
wouldn't be practical
in the real world,
and we are then
testing our system
the same way that it
will be actually stress
tested in the real world.
So it's another place
where Kubernetes
is super useful for
us and another reason
why it's a really great
platform in general.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS: Yeah,
we do something pretty similar
actually.
I mean, no robots for us, but
we run an endpoint on agents,
and I can just build the
endpoint into containers
and spin a hundred,
a thousand of them up
in a Kubernetes cluster and
just point them somewhere.
So we basically
do the same thing.
And it's a really easy
way to just sort of
have a really elastic--
oh, you know, cool.
Let's point to
hundreds of these then.
Well, do we have
enough capacity there,
which gives us a good
understanding of the number
of endpoints that can
correspond with what size pods
and how many pods.
What does our horizontal
scaling look like?
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: So
now actually move back
to database question.
So database is stable.
So how do you use
together Kubernetes?
Are you putting database
in the Kubernetes pod?
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS: So
we don't run our databases
inside Kubernetes.
We use Cloud SQL.
It's great.
It just runs.
We don't think
very much about it.
The way Kubernetes
talks to Cloud SQL,
it's got a couple
of intermediaries.
So we use the Cloud
SQL Proxy which
is designed to
proxy between things
like Kubernetes and Cloud SQL.
Google distributes it.
You just kind of tell it to go.
And we run Postgres,
which means we also
need some additional
connection pooling.
So each of our customer pods--
excuse me, each of our
customer namespaces
has Cloud SQL proxy instances
and PG balancer instances
as like an additional
connection pooling layer there.
JOE HUGHES: We actually started
running databases inside
of containers, again
being more cautious.
Postgres for Cloud SQL's in
beta, and we were like, well,
we'll just wait.
And so we waited.
In that time, we
had decent success.
Kubernetes is a pretty
stable platform.
Using persistent
volume claims, which
allows you to have a disk
that follows your pod around,
we had minimal problems.
But certainly the
effort was not zero.
I spent a lot of
time tuning that.
When we had the need
for a read replica,
that was a couple weeks out of
my time to make that a thing.
And since moving away
from that model--
and then there was
also the problems.
And so the problems are like,
uh oh, alert just went off.
I'm running out of disk space.
Got to go in there and
get more disk space.
That's not a problem
on Cloud SQL.
Just that auto scales
right up for you.
And so that was
actually the main thing
that I was running away from.
When that finally came out of
beta, I was like OK, great.
No more disk-space problems,
better alerting, and looking
forward to the day where also
auto scaling on Cloud SQL
takes that out of the
equation for me as well.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN:
So whenever you
have to create an
instance in the Cloud SQL,
are you using Kubernetes
or Terraform to automate
that whole process?
JOE HUGHES: Yeah, so our whole
thing is driven by Terraform.
I've been using Terraform
for quite a few years.
It's a great product.
And what it allows
me to do is create
what's called a
Terraform module, which
is much like what Seph was
alluding to for an operator,
but that module represents
what is a customer,
and that customer is a
Cloud SQL instance, a DNS
entry, a namespace, and
all this other stuff.
And then there's this
tool called Atlantis
which allows you to
manage all of these things
through GitHub pull requests.
And so essentially an
upgrade in our world
is a GitHub pull request,
and then Atlantis
runs Terraform and makes
all those things happen.
So it's really elegant
for us, but there's always
room for improvement
in that sort of thing.
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
Yeah, for us
it's all driven by
our operator, which
is a daemon that we wrote.
It runs in Kubernetes, but
it isn't part of Kubernetes.
It could run anywhere we put it.
We just run everything in
Kubernetes, so that too.
And it goes, it calls
the API for Cloud SQL,
creates it, waits
for it to show up,
makes sure it does
what it wants,
and then it creates
everything else.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: All right.
So I think we are almost
at the time for Q&A,
but I want to ask
the last question.
How many DBAs do you
have in your team?
JOSEPH SOKOL-MARGOLIS:
Just me, really.
JOE HUGHES: I would
say zero only because I
don't consider myself a DBA.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: That's great.
JOE HUGHES: I am the guy
that's on call, I guess.
AMY KRISHNAMOHAN: OK.
Awesome.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]